TRIP ADVISORIES: WORLD CUP
EDITION.
THE WORLD CUP IS HAPPENING THIS
MONTH.
TOURISTS ACROSS THE WORLD HAVE
BEEN FLOCKING TO BRAZIL.
BUT WITH STADIUMS BARELY
COMPLETED IN TIME FOR THE GAMES,
THERE ARE PROBABLY GOING TO BE
SOME COMPLAINTS BY TRAVELERS.
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
LINES FROM TRIPADVISOR REVIEWS
THAT WOULD MAKE YOU STAY AWAY
FROM BRAZILIAN HOTELS AND OTHER
WORLD CUP DESTINATIONS.
THE WAY YOU IDENTIFY A
BRAZILIAN HOTEL IS ITS ASS AND
PUSSY ARE COMPLETELY BARE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I JUST SAID
THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> I BROKE ERIN A LITTLE BIT.
>> THAT ONE TOOK ME OFF GUARD.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, STARTING NOW.
GO. YES, JAY.
>> THERE'S A GUY IN MY BATH TUB
WHO WHENEVER I TAKE A ( BLEEP ),
HE YELLS GOOOOAL!
>> POINTS. YEAH, RANDY.
>> GOT STABBED WHILE VISITING
THE LOBBY GIFT SHOP.
ON THE PLUS SIDE, WHEN I WENT TO
THE HOSPITAL, ALL THE NURSES
WERE TOPLESS.
OK, GOOD JOB, POINTS. RANDY.
ERIN.
>> EVERY NIGHT AT MY HOTEL IN
THE BARRIO, THEY PUT AN ORPHAN
ON MY PILLOW.
POINTS. JAY.
>> HARDLY ANY CARPET IN THE
ROOM.
JUST ONE THIN STRIP RIGHT UP THE
MIDDLE.
>> NICE, POINTS.
>> AND IT DOESN'T MATCH THE
DRAPES.
>> IT DOES NOT MATCH THE DRAPES.
>> THIS IS MORE GENERAL-- BUT DO
NOT BUY YOUR SEX WORKERS AT THE
AIRPORT.
THEY CHARGE THREE TIME AS MUCH.
>> POINTS. YEAH. ERIN
ERIN.
>> THE STATUE OF CHRIST THE
REDEEMER HAS A GLORY HOLE.